[Music]
is
[Music]
we're gonna get started in just a few
[Music]
minutes
[Music]
she's got to be
let it take our time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
well good morning everyone i i want to
begin today with a very heavy heart
and tell you about the passing of david
dinkins
i'm feeling a lot right now sherlane's
feeling a lot this is someone who
meant so much to us and was a guiding
hand in our lives in so many ways
but what he did for the city
i think the way to say it is he simply
put us on a better path
he did it with heart and
warmth and love he was animated by love
for people all people
and david dinkins
believed that we could be better he
believed we could overcome our divisions
he showed us what it was like
to be a gentleman to be a kind person
no matter what was thrown at him and a
lot was thrown at him
and he always tried to answer the hate
with love
uh it was remarkable serving with him
in this building to see that no matter
what was going on out there
he always had that joy that he found
and it was particularly for children he
loved children so deeply and he
did something about it creating those
amazing beacon after school programs
that continued to this day
that we've actually been expanding to
reach more and more kids
this is something he believed in so
deeply everything that we could do for
our children
and he had a wisdom
an ability to stay steady no matter
how choppy the waters it was just
extraordinary
and it's hard to be that patient
and that kind when there's so many
troubles all around you but he did it
and he made things happen for this city
that he's really never gotten the credit
for including
putting us on the pathway to becoming a
much safer city
with the safe street safe city program
and all the affordable housing that he
launched
and the generation of
really devoted public servants that got
their start
and shirlene and i are humbly among
that generation that we would never have
had the opportunity to serve
our city if it weren't for david dinkins
and i'm speaking now to the
hundreds and hundreds of people who are
part of the team
in the years 1989 to 1983 and
just saying to all of you i'm expressing
my love
to all of you how much we miss david
dinkins right now
and yet we still have each other and
that's the way he would have wanted it
he really worked constantly to nurture
the next generation
and whenever he's around you felt
reassured
because he he was there for all the
right reasons so
i'm feeling something painful in my
heart right now i'm feeling like a loss
and an emptiness
because he's gone but i also really
feel his guidance still
his presence and we're gonna keep going
we're gonna continue his fight
he used that phrase gorgeous mosaic
that was sort of his signature phrase
and i don't want anyone to miss the
meaning of that
because if you're around it he would say
it and he felt it he felt it deeply it
wasn't just like a throwaway line
and some people would mock it but they
weren't paying attention to the
the truth he meant to say
first of all how much he just loved
people he loved humanity he saw the
beauty in new yorkers
he saw the gorgeous reality of the city
even
even when it was tough he still saw the
good and mosaic meant
every one of us every one of our
communities
our cultures could shine through it
didn't need to be a contradiction or a
conflict
we could all add up to something greater
and at the time a lot of people didn't
use that phrase i'd like to say melting
pot
which suggests taking away our unique
features
and culture he didn't see it that way he
thought
each beautiful strand should shine
through
and it could lead to something greater
and it did
so david dinkins god bless you we miss
you already
but we all learned a lot we all became
better because of you
and we're going to carry on your work
and rest in peace
everybody
we can talk about the great people we've
lost
or we can do something even better which
is to honor them
and follow their lessons and one thing
that mayor dinkins always cared about
was uplifting other people
and and helping people and so now
we come into this holiday season as a
time
that's supposed to be about joy
this year it's also a time we have to be
really careful
and the way we uplift each other is to
protect each other right now
it's about protecting each other and
it's about
realizing that the most beautiful thing
we can do for someone we love is make
sure they stay safe
make sure they're alive for next year
when we get to celebrate in person again
so today we're going to talk about
several things
we're going to start with the idea that
for lots of families
instead of travel they have opportunity
to
stay connected virtually it's not the
same thing i'm not here to tell you
it's the same thing i'm not going to see
some of the people i love the most
i normally traveled almost every
thanksgiving
i'm not doing that and i'm going to miss
people just painfully
but for the folks who are other places
i'm going to connect with them virtually
and
it won't be as good i'm not going to lie
to you but it will count
we'll feel it so the first thing we want
to talk about today
is a major new development
which is something that will allow more
and more people to stay connected
in times like this obviously or with the
people they love
even if they don't live here or stay
connected to the world
and to the things they need and to the
opportunities they deserve
we've had a digital divide we've had a
huge disparity of who gets
access to internet who doesn't who gets
reliable fast broadband service who
doesn't
who can afford it who can't but more and
more
we understand that we have to create a
society in which everyone has equal
access
and so today we have a major
announcement
after a lot of work on many city
agencies
we've come to an agreement that is going
to require verizon
to build out its fios footprint to reach
now an additional 500 000
households here in new york city this is
going to be a requirement
of this agreement 500 000 households
that do not get this service now have to
be reached
and the priority will put be put on the
community has been most
underserved and there's a specific
guarantee that
each building in public housing every
nycha building
will be reached with this service will
be part of this
fios footprint uh it has taken a lot of
work
and there's been some real struggle here
and some real challenges
but we've gone to a point where
something real and tangible is going to
happen for people particularly working
people
and folks who have been left out and
many people worked on it but no one
worked on it with more passion and
resolve than our corporation council so
i want him to speak to this
my pleasure introduced corporation
council of the city of new york jim
johnson
good morning and thank you mayor this
morning most of us participating on this
call got our news from a high-speed
connection to the internet
we may have spoken to a family member in
a video chat or even helped the family
member get online for a meeting
or class and that's not been so easy for
many new yorkers due to a lack of
franchise investment
in our least connected communities and
so
in 2014 the city began these proceedings
against verizon
because verizon had failed to meet the
terms of its cable franchise agreement
and that had been during the bloomberg
administration and the goal of that was
to build out its
network but the city's goal is to make
sure that the
digital divide is
shut down closed
and so we brought this case and we now
have resolved it so that more new
yorkers will have access to this vital
tool
and the pandemic has only underscored
how critical this need is
it's needed for us to draw close
together as family members it's needed
for our children to study
this resolution could not be more timely
many of the neighborhoods that have the
most to gain from the settlement are
those that were hardest hit by covet 19.
those are the ones with low median
household incomes
and the fewest options sometimes no
options for affordable broad
broadband at a minimum
verizon will make connections available
to 125 000 additional households in
those community districts
just in those community districts
and more importantly overall
the settlement ensures that a half a
million households
the previous black verizon brought back
access because
of their its corporate failure to invest
in the infrastructure they'll now have
the option of fiber broadband
and it will also create critical cost
competition in areas where today
only one provider exists and when
there's a monopoly
there's often higher prices and we want
to drive the prices down
the settlement also ensures transparency
the terms of the settlement call for
verizon to report on a quarterly basis
on how they are making proc it's making
progress
um and the city was going to make public
the list of newly eligible house loads
households so people will know when
services come
to their part of our community
this is an important settlement because
it highlights the city's commitment to
holding franchisees accountable
to meet their commitments to the public
it also contains enforcement terms and
we will both monitor compliance
and ensure enforcement as we go forward
thank you mayor
thank you so much jim and jim i want to
thank you everyone at the law department
i want to thank our
i.t commissioner jesse tish i want to
thank
our chief technology officer john paul
farmer everyone who worked together on
this
uh first she may want to thank our
deputy mayor
for operations laura anglin her team
everyone who worked on this
because it is a labor of love to make
sure that people really had the access
they deserved
so thank you thank you for this strong
action
to close the digital divide
thank you very much jim everyone now as
we think about
this new announcement again it goes back
to the fact that
even though we're working to get
everyone the access they deserve
thank god a lot of families do have that
access and that means
they have the opportunity to stay in
touch virtually and the boy has that
been important during this crisis
so many people it's been their only way
to stay connected and particularly for a
lot of our seniors
uh it's been absolutely crucial who
couldn't go out couldn't expose
themselves this disease
and so we want to remember that as we
now approach the holidays that
again it will not be easy
but we've got to stay safe and i'll keep
telling people please
if you do not need to travel don't
travel unless there's a really really
crucial reason don't travel it's just
going to only add
more exposure to this disease more
chance that
you might get it your family might get
it might be brought back here
inadvertently
so i'm asking everyone again please
avoid
travel celebrate with your loved ones in
other places virtually
and here to amplify the things that we
need to do to protect each other and
stay safe in this holiday season
our health commissioner dr dave choxey
thank you mr mayor thanksgiving is two
days away
i know many new yorkers are making tough
decisions
about how to connect with family friends
and loved ones let me start by saying
clearly
it is not too late to cancel your travel
plans
now is the moment to make a difference
in this next wave of the pandemic
covet 19 numbers are rising across new
york city and throughout the country
but new yorkers know how to work
together because of new yorkers hard
work
and care we flattened the curve before
and we can continue to slow the spread
now
it is so important that new yorkers
follow our new guidance for the holidays
stay safe stay home do not travel this
holiday season
if it can be at all avoided
stay safe stay home is our clear message
to new yorkers
this season you'll see it on ads that
will run on subway live
boards link nyc the staten island ferry
and on social media all the way into
january
and look i understand this isn't easy
the holidays center around togetherness
my wife and i usually host thanksgiving
for our extended family i have fond
memories of
of our thanksgiving from last year um
which was uh the first time that my
daughter tasted
solid food surrounded by many doting
relatives
just as an aside her first solid food
was
a korean sweet potato because she is
after all a queen's baby
so i am sad that this year's
thanksgiving will be different
uh mostly virtual like so much else but
it is necessary
we know gathering in groups even small
groups
is causing the virus to spread please be
cautious
and stick to your core groups of family
members and select friends
here's one way to think about it you
bring everyone you've been around
with you to your holiday celebration
now while the holidays may look
different there are ways to keep their
spirit
alive particularly at a time that is so
difficult for new yorkers
we have collectively suffered during
this pandemic
with the loss of family members and
neighbors
separation and economic hardships
first and foremost i urge you reach out
to your friends
family and neighbors particularly those
who you may have noticed are struggling
a simple phone call goes a long way and
we can be creative in how we connect
with our friends and family we can of
course still enjoy the holidays together
you can take a walk in the park or go
for a bike ride
enjoy the fresh air relax and try to get
in some exercise
you can plan a virtual trivia game or
plan to cook the same
family recipe even if you're doing it in
in kitchens that are in different states
but for all of these activities
please remember to practice the same old
new
rules wear a face covering both outdoors
and indoors keep six feet of distance
and gather outdoors whenever possible
wash your hands frequently
and stay home if you're not feeling well
and get
tested particularly if you plan to
travel or to gather with others
this thanksgiving as the mayor said the
best way to express our gratitude for
our loved ones
is by keeping our celebrations small and
finally i want to salute our healthcare
heroes
and our essential workers many of whom
will be working
over the holidays do your part to help
keep them safe
thank you thank you very much doctor and
now
we've given you all our best guidance
everything that the science and the data
the
healthcare reality is telling us but we
know
people sometimes will have to travel and
we do understand in those cases that the
most important thing is to do it
safely to really follow the guidance
follow the rules
and we're going to make sure that people
are reminded constantly
throughout this whole holiday season if
you travel there are very clear rules
you have to follow
and you're going to see the presence of
the city of new york
when you travel particularly through our
sheriff's office you're going to see
that there are really clear rules to be
followed and they will be enforced
and you're going to know that if someone
does not follow those rules
uh that there are real penalties
substantial financial penalties that
will be applied no one likes that no one
wants to do that the holidays but we
will do it to keep people safe
so here to tell you about all our
efforts to
make sure people travel safely and
follow the rules that will keep us
all safe our sheriff joe fasito
thank you mr mayor good morning everyone
and happy holidays
as the mayor stated the city of new york
provides tremendous support for people
tremendous education but there has to be
enforcement in order to keep everyone
safe
so go over just some highlights of how
we're going to be keeping enforcement
regarding the compliance with the travel
quarantine and the standing emergency
orders
sheriff teams will be out in force as
the holidays approach
there will be vehicle checkpoints at key
bridges and crossings throughout new
york city
the sheriff will also be conducting
checkpoints at curbside
drop-off bus stops so out-of-state buses
coming into new york city when they drop
off at the curb
they will be met by sheriff teams
the t2 team and the sheriff will also be
serving
department of health general orders for
travelers arriving in new york
advising him of the quarantine and what
they have to do in order to comply with
the quarantine
in addition the sheriff's office will be
sending out emails
will also include robo calls and tech
text messages
if you sign up with the new york state
traveler
website if you violate the travel
quarantine
there will be consequences violation of
a self-quarantined travel regulation may
result in deputy sheriffs
serving you a mandatory quarantine order
issued by the health commissioner in
cases of violation
deputies could serve you with a civil
summons that carries a thousand dollar
fine
as a practical matter and as the mayor
stated previously the sheriff's office
would be concentrating
on large-scale gatherings our actions in
the last several months have reinforced
this point
deputy sheriffs are investigating
massive events that violate
a panoply of criminal fire building
health and other regulatory laws at
locations such as illegal fight clubs
underground raves and illegal gambling
debts
these activities were illegal and
sometimes deadly before covet 19
and the public safety hazards regarding
them have been amplified
exponentially by the pandemic
in the city of 8.3 million people the
best and most pragmatic method for
deputy sheriffs to save lives
is to maximize enforcement at these
types of dangerous gatherings
that is an overall view of how our
enforcement is going to be moving
forward in the months to come
and i give it back to the mayor thank
you so much
i want to thank you sheriff joe fasito
and your whole team
for what you guys have been doing it's
been absolutely crucial
and we really appreciate the way you've
been out there no matter what keeping
people safe and i know you're going to
continue to throughout the holiday
season
let's now talk about our indicators for
the day a number one daily number of
people admitted to new york city
hospitals for suspected covet 19
threshold 200 patients today's report
113 with a positivity level for covet of
40.83 so again
seeing pretty stable reality there that
number is higher than we want to be both
the positivity and the number of
patients but we're not seeing
uh the huge expansion that some of the
other numbers might suggest we're
keeping a close eye on that
that is a very interesting and important
factor
number two though we see something
that's exactly the opposite of what we
want
new reported cases on a seven day
average threshold 550 cases
today's report 1 476 cases again we have
to do everything we can to turn this
around
and that depends on every one of us and
number three percentage of people
testing
positive citywide for kobe 19 threshold
five percent now today's report on the
daily
that information is still not ready the
number that came out today was
clearly artificially high because it was
based on very limited test results so
that number is going to be
updated as more results come in we'll
get the accurate number out later on
today but the
seven day rolling average uh we have
confidence in that
is 3.17 percent
say a few words in spanish
importante
[Music]
with that let's turn to our colleagues
in the media and please let me know the
name and outlet
of each journalist we'll now begin our q
a
as a reminder we're joined today by dr
choxie
uh by sheriff fusito by dewitt
commissioner jesse tish
uh by corporation council jim johnson
and by senior advisor
dr j varma the first question today goes
to juan manuel benitez
from new york one
good morning mr mayor good morning juan
manuel how are you
very good thank you if there was one
lesson
you learned from mayor duncan's can you
tell us
what main lesson was
thank you for asking juan manuel um
the power of love he he really loved
people he loved children in particular
and he would always show children that
he would show them they were loved
i remember he would when he was around
groups of kids
particularly kids of color he would say
to them you know you can be mayor you
know he had become mayor he would tell
them you can become mayor too and he
really was trying to encourage them
and you know he would he would try and
treat people with love even when they
were treating him with hate
so i think what i remember is his
extraordinary ability to summon
the love he felt and put that forward no
matter what was thrown at him
go ahead
juan manuel yes
okay so this morning on the radio mr
mayor you said that
when we get into december we're gonna
start working to reopen our schools
can you clarify if that means that
you're going to start the process of
thinking how to reopen schools in the
city or that you are
really going to start reopening a
specific
number of schools in the month of
december
juan juan manuel i spoke to this
yesterday i'm going to say it again the
we're going to be in an orange zone in
december
the orange zone rules for opening
schools are clear they're very stringent
but we can meet that standard it's going
to take a lot of work and as i said
parents are going to be really involved
but we can do it we're going to start
with the special education schools the
district 75 schools
work our way up pre-k 3k
and elementary it's going to take a
lot of work that we've never had to do
on this level before
so we're shifting a lot of testing
resources over
but we will keep reopening schools and
we want to fight back this second wave
and especially as we fight it back
successfully we'll be able to speed up
that process
go ahead the next is matt chase from
newsday
hey good morning mr mayor how are you
good man how you doing today
i'm doing okay i wanted to ask you
briefly about david dinkins
um can you discuss his legacy with
regards to the crown heights riots
yeah it's so interesting matt do you say
that because just
yesterday i was in crown heights
just by sheer coincidence
doing something that really i know david
dinkins
would have loved which is you know
providing the support to open
a new educational facility uh for medgar
evers prep for a wonderful high school
uh that's gonna be that is there on the
campus is now gonna have the kind of
home it deserves
and um richard greene was there
one of the heroes of the years after
those horrible days in in 1991
when the community in the years after
found its way together again
uh people of different backgrounds
really worked hard i want
you know say every community
participated in crown heights and
richard green was one of the great
leaders of that reconciliation so so
interesting he was there yesterday and i
greeted him and
i think back on the pain of those times
matt it was a very very difficult time
and it was a
a real perfect storm for sure how that
all happened
but i also think there is a heroic story
that has not been told of what people in
the community did thereafter and brought
a unity to crown heights today
uh that is actually affirming of what
people can do
when they overcome their divisions go
ahead matt
um on another topic um last night
in your interview with errol lewis you
said
uh that you're going to be checking on
people constantly uh and this was a
quote and if
people don't follow the quarantine there
will be substantial financial penalties
and we're going to make that very vivid
so my question is
how will enforcers decide whom to check
in on among those returning from out of
town travel
well i'll start and i'll see if the
sheriff wants to add
um the idea here
is or or dr long may want to add as well
the idea here is it's quite clear
that you have to follow up fill out
excuse me that traveler form
that the only way to not participate in
quarantine is to follow the state rules
and do the testing before you come back
and the testing after you come back
but if you don't do that and you don't
succeed with that
you have to be in quarantine and so what
we're making very clear is we're going
to be constantly monitoring people if
they're not in quarantine when they're
supposed to be
we have to apply penalties this is not
you know this is not a drill this is not
a test this is the real thing what's
bearing down on us
and we have to be stringent about it so
let me see if the sheriff
or dr long want to add yes
so the test and trace team does a
significant amount of outreach to people
and follow-up they make sure that people
are following the quarantine
they do other types of investigation and
then if they feel that there is a
violation
they may ask the sheriff's office to get
involved to look a little bit further
and then in the last several weeks we've
been issuing uh
we've been serving uh mandatory
quarantine orders so if the test and
trace team feels that you violated the
quarantine and they have evidence of it
then they'll elevate it that it'll be a
mandatory quarantine
and if you violate the mandatory
quarantine then there would be
a legal action taken against you most
likely civil action where you'd be
served with a civil summons
but we have made arrests and charged
somebody with a misdemeanor for
violating the quarantine and why don't
you just help people understand what the
kind of financial penalties are there
sure so the financial penalty for the
civil violation is a thousand dollars
so if you violate the quarantine and
every time you violate the quarantine
you could be fined a thousand dollars
that means
each day each day each day
okay uh dr long you want to add
yeah thank you sir i just want to make
two additional points here and this is
reflecting what you
i said just a moment ago we want to do
everything in our power to help you in
order to quarantine
we've made 2.9 million calls to new
yorkers offering services including our
free hotel program
in addition to that the only way to not
serve the 14 days of quarantine which is
the right thing to keep
new york city safe is if you get tested
before you come back
that's negative and then on the fourth
day when you are back
in order to help you do that we're doing
something innovative
at jfk today at the jetblue terminal
we're handing out a self-test kits to
you as you get on the plane
that you can use before you come back to
make it very easy
for you to test out of the quarantine
requirement and
to prove that you're negative to keep
new york city safe so
um we're doing everything that we can in
order to help you to get through the
quarantine thank you sir
thank you and to emphasize if
people test out because they had a
negative before they came back and they
had another negative when they got back
that's ideal that's wonderful but if
people test positive
they're going to be in quarantine if
they don't follow the testing regime
they're going to be in quarantine if
they violate the quarantine you just
heard what the sheriff said there will
be financial penalties
and they'll be repeated if people
violate multiple days and we don't want
to see that happen but if it has to it
will and we're going to be very clear
about
those consequences and what's going on
with them go ahead
the next is gwen from wnyc
hey mr mayor can you hear me yeah how
you doing
i'm doing all right thanks so much for
taking my question um you know i wanted
to ask a follow-up about this wedding in
williamsburg
when specifically did the city learn
about this wedding was it
before it happened was it during or was
it after
and you know it's right next to an fdny
fire station house there were thousands
of people here
was the fdny not aware that it was
happening do you think
fifteen thousand dollars isn't for the
deterrent and
can you and the health commissioner give
us lots of questions hold on just
let's stay where you were you can you'll
have a follow-up
question right it just is we can't we
can't do justice to so many at once
um we all find out
uh well i know let me say what i do know
we
we did not know before or during that
much
uh has been established as we've
investigated what happened
i don't have a full answer on if folks
in the firehouse
knew we also don't know the final number
of people
the reporting suggests a certain number
i'm not sure that is the number what we
do know
is unquestionably it was too many people
whatever that number was whether it was
hundreds thousands it was too many
people
and it appears that there was a very
conscious effort
to conceal what was going on and that's
what makes it even more unacceptable
uh fifteen thousand dollars is a very
serious fine a cease and desist order
has now been placed on that building
uh if there were further inappropriate
activity
that is the precursor to the building
being shut down permanently
um we don't want to see that happen to
anyone but we need to be very very clear
that if
folks are doing something dangerous uh
we can't allow it to happen go ahead
can you hear me gwen
hi hi again sorry about that um can you
can you give new yorkers specific
examples that your health commissioner
has found
of large indoor gatherings like this
that have led to confirmed cases of
covid
can you give us examples of those
so i'll start and uh dr choxie dr
long can jump in let's be clear
that we've had enforcement on large
gatherings i want to thank the sheriff
and his team they've been
very aggressive and effective at
breaking up large gatherings
but over the last week or two we've been
asked a lot of different questions about
what test and trace is found
what they're finding is a much more
diffuse pattern
of where tests are coming from that
they're not at this moment
coming from the larger gatherings as far
as we're seeing now you go back some
months we definitely saw some connection
to larger gatherings
but even if we're not tracing specific
cases back to the larger gatherings
right this minute we know how dangerous
they are we know they have the potential
to spread the disease really intensely
and quickly
and that's why we have to protect
against them and by the way it's the law
dr choxey dr long you want to add yes
sir well the mayor said it well
i'll just add our goal is always focused
on prevention the more that we can
ensure that large gatherings do not
happen because there is very
clear-cut scientific evidence of how
large gatherings can spread the
coronavirus that means we can
interrupt further transmission uh the
mayor is right there have not been
um you know large super spreader events
in uh in recent weeks um and i think
that is
uh in large part because new yorkers are
heeding our guidance uh and because our
law enforcement colleagues are
um are doing their jobs well um but my
plea
is as we see more people becoming
infected
more people who are coming into
our emergency departments and hospitals
it is unconscionable
for people to have those larger events
when we know they facilitate spread
dr long anything that
dr long can you hear us answer okay but
you can hear me now yes there you go
thank you sir so the only thing i would
add i think you actually said it the
important point which is that we've not
seen
large events we've seen a series of
smaller events
it's important as doctor chokshi said to
prevent those from happening
in the first place where people are
exposed but one point i want to make
is that contact tracing is
forward-looking and
as we've detected these smaller events
we've been able to effectively
intervene to break the chains of
transmission by reaching out to the
people at the events
we just announced our recent numbers
yesterday for our contact racing across
the city
despite having cases that have gone from
around 200 today to now 1300 plus a day
we're reaching 95 of every single case
across
new york city and completing interviews
and getting all the information we need
to do contact tracing
for 81 of all cases across new york city
new yorkers are coming together getting
tested and participating
and that's making an incredible
difference and that's how we are doing
how we're holding the virus at bayes
city thank you
thank you a quick programming note
before we go forward we're also joined
by
chief technology officer john paul
farmer the next question goes to nolan
from the post
good morning everybody hey nolan how are
you
i'm all right if i could just follow up
on gwen's questions about
the wedding at the shul in south
williamsburg
the fines fifteen thousand dollars the
building has a capacity for seven
thousand people that's
two bucks ahead how is that truly a
deterrent
i think a fifteen thousand dollar fine
gets people's attention but i think the
cease and desist order
is crucial here uh from this point on if
there's
any further illegal activity in that
building the building will be closed
down i think that's a pretty clear
deterrent
go ahead and on the larger question of
enforcement you've been depending on the
sheriff's off from the sheriff's
department
and your office of special enforcement
to do much of
of the work of enforcing social
distancing regulations around the city
we have a wedding where thousands of
people showed up apparently without city
hall getting wind of it
we have a party scene that's so rampant
new york magazine splashed it on their
cover this week
what does that say about enforcement in
the city it kind of feels like a joke
well no one it's been very very
consistent
it's a big city over 8 million people
it's a huge geography to cover and yet
consistently when there's been a problem
the sheriff's office
office special enforcement they've done
outstanding work they've shut down
lots of events uh i think it's quite
clear
you know you're going to see some things
that unfortunately still happen but
overwhelmingly
i give them a lot of credit they've been
able to identify things and act on them
quickly
the next is andrew siff from wnbc
good morning mr mayor and everyone on
the call mayor
mike mulgrew is now saying that he does
not believe that mayoral control of
schools
should continue i'm wondering what your
reaction to that is
i haven't seen the specific comments but
i can tell you what mayoral
control has allowed us to do and you
know look i didn't agree with
mayor bloomberg on a number of things
but i think it was a really
important achievement i give him credit
because
it allowed for progress to happen in our
schools that had
not happened for decades and between his
time as mayor and my time as mayor
the graduation rate has gone up 50
percent
we've been able to get so much more to
happen schools we could never have done
a pre-k for all without mayoral control
we could never have reopened our schools
and even though we're all in pain now
that they're closed temporarily
they'll be coming back and we had two
full months our schools were open
could never have done that without
mayoral control
it's the only way uh to move things
forward because there's actual
accountability
to the people and the other systems that
were tried in the past did not provide
that so
there'll be a big discussion on it
debate on it but i think the people of
this city will see that they
they want our schools to be better all
the time and they need to hold someone
accountable and that should be the mayor
go ahead issue of reopening schools i
i know you've talked about the phased
reopening starting with the special
needs kids then pre-k and 3k then
elementary school
how soon could we see that happen could
you start reopening
special ed schools as soon as next week
and if not why not right now andrew it's
something i'm going to talk through
with the state with the governor about
the right now the rule is we would have
to wait for the orange zone to be
designated
we all agree governor said i've said
orange zone is coming to new york city
no one's happy about it but the numbers
are very clear
that requires a very specific approach
to school reopening
um we can start that clock when the
orange zone is declared
i'm going to talk to albany about
whether there's any way to speed that up
in light of the fact that we're already
shut down now
but whatever way you slice it
once we have satisfied the state's time
requirements
will be opening in the meantime we are
going to get that testing in place
because it's a big endeavor you have to
test the school community in advance of
reopening
and you have to do regular testing in
the schools so we're going to shift a
lot of our testing resources into it
that's why we need that phased approach
also but we're going to do it our
school's going to come back and as i
said i believe
from december on each month should get
better
as we get past the holidays as we start
to feel the effect of the vaccine
and we'll be able to keep opening up
more and more and then hopefully more
and more days per week for kids
as we go along the next is yahood from
borough park 24 news
hi good morning mr mayor how are you i'm
doing well yeah how are you
great um thank you so among the crimes
um
two nights ago in brooklyn seven people
were shot and one person was killed in
one apartment building
another 17 year old boy was wounded by a
drive-by shooting and there was also an
early morning stabbing yesterday in
borough park
so last week the new york um police
department reported that shootings in
new york city have increased by almost
95 percent last year but
um the number of arrests police have
made has actually fallen by 13
so i was wondering what kind of plans
you and the nypd have to decrease
crime and increase arrest
yeah thank you for the question look
we're going to overcome this this has
all been caused by the massive
dislocation
of this coronavirus crisis and i keep
saying it's a perfect storm because it
has been a perfect storm we've seen
everything possible go wrong at once
people lost their jobs schools were
closed houses of worship are closed you
name it
we are now fighting back in fact the
number of gun
arrests continues to climb the nypd is
getting more and more guns off the
street the problem with the city the
problem with this country there's too
many guns out there to begin with
but we are fighting back and we will
overcome it there's no question in my
mind
the nypd is moving the resources where
they're needed most
and as we recover more and more
we're going to be able to fight crime
back down we've done it before we're
going to do it again
go ahead
also yesterday you were talking about
the great help that the federal stimulus
would be
and um last week we were reading about
how the mta
is currently 1.4 billion dollars in debt
and so in addition to waiting for a
federal relief
package other possible solutions the
board's considering are
cutting weekday subway service in half
and eliminating the jobs of more than
nine thousand transit workers
some say to raise fares and tolls and
some actually say to lower fares and
totals to increase ridership i was just
wondering the sides for waiting for the
federal aid package what steps do you
think that the mta could do
to get out of debt and maintain service
at a level that new yorkers need
well it's such a powerful question but i
have to say i don't think anything
replaces the federal stimulus there's
just the sheer cold math of it all
there's no way the state
can come up with the kind of money the
mta
needs to avoid some of the problems it's
facing
we're all struggling right now because
you know
certainly i can say from the city
perspective we're constantly spending
more and more to protect people to get
them health care
to get them food there's so much
need the state is struggling as well so
we need the federal
stimulus if we don't have the federal
stimulus i fear you will see less mta
service and that just won't be good for
the city but
i also appreciate the mta has a horrible
situation
and i think this is why we should
remember stimulus equals recovery
stimulus equals economic recovery that's
why we need it
go ahead we've time for two more for
today
the next is paul leota from the staten
island advance
good morning mr mayor hey paul how you
doing
i'm well sir thank you um i just had a
question regarding hospital capacity on
staten island
with the state uh reopening the field
hospital i just wanted to see
if the city had any intention of
providing assistance to
hospitals on staten island yeah paul
absolutely i mean
i'm very concerned about the situation
of staten island
and i know staten island went through so
much in the spring
we focused of course in getting the ppe
to hospitals in the spring
and working with both hospitals
regularly on their needs
we've got to be very careful this time
to make sure the staten islanders get
what they need so we'll be talking to
the hospitals
about their ppe supply about staffing
whatever it is they need will work with
the state as well to make sure
staten islanders are safe this time as
much as we are deeply concerned about a
second wave
one thing we can say for sure paul is
all our hospitals
learned a lot from the painful
experience of the spring they're all
better positioned
to fight the coronavirus this time but
we will definitely the city will
definitely be there to help staten
island hospitals
in any way we can go ahead
thank you and uh with the dangers of
this upcoming weekend
i'm just curious what role the nypd will
play
in enforcement
look we are going to constantly
remind people that if they're traveling
they have to follow the rules we just
talked about that's going to be
primarily the sheriff's
office handling that uh we're going to
be very careful about large
uh public gatherings the kinds we were
talking about a few minutes ago
hundreds of people anything like that we
will obviously intervene
to stop um you know just think about as
it gets colder and colder if people are
indoor
by the hundreds or the thousands that's
just unfortunately a breeding ground for
covid
so we'll we'll be out there but again
another
we understand that each individual
family
is going to make their own choice we've
given them the best guidance they're
going to make their choice
they're certainly not going to be any
enforcement in terms of families
it's going to be travel and it's going
to be large events that we're watching
out for
last question for today it goes to gersh
from streets blog
hello mr mayor first i want to thank you
for your kind words about mayor dinkins
thank you guys you you i think you you
observed his career and you know what a
good man he was
at the bottom line very much so anyway
if we could get back to
commissioner trottenberg's resignation
when vision zero was announced in 2014
the goal was to eliminate all traffic
deaths by 2024.
now oslo norway did it helsinki finland
did it
zero road fatalities last year now
they're smaller cities obviously but in
new york city overall deaths
have dropped from about 250 a year when
you took office to about 220 so far this
year
following last year which was also a
very dangerous year on the road so a
simple question
why are so many people still dying on
the roads of new york city
well we definitely have more work to do
i mean look we you know over the course
of the
seven years we had some moments where
we're able to have
really extraordinary success and we've
had some setbacks too
but the basic concept works and it will
continue to work it will continue to
deepen
uh what i hope gersh is that the success
of vision zero
will be amplified not only this next
year while i'm mayor but by the next
mayor as well
because every single street redesign
helps
all the enforcement helps all the speed
cameras help we just got to keep doing
it
and it does change behavior and then
ultimately continuing to build out mass
transit to give people that much better
option so
uh i'm i am certain this is the model
that will protect people in the future
go ahead gersch it's a slightly
different question you know i think we
can all agree even i think the trump
administration agrees at this point that
the election of joe biden actually
happened
so i wonder if you will ask the nypd to
remove the barricades from many streets
which they closed off on the grounds
that there might be post-election
violence
yeah gersh my strong impression i'll
check with the commissioner but that
process has been going on already um
that
the whole idea was to continually reduce
the use of barricades i'll i'll check
for the current status but i
i think it has begun to happen and will
happen even more
in the coming days with
that let me just close
just one more reflection on mayor
dinkins because it's such a
painful and poignant day and look
everyone
i want to express my thanks i want to
express my thanks to
all new yorkers for everything you've
done to
fight your way through this crisis i
want to express my thanks to all my
colleagues who do this good work on your
behalf
but i'm really particularly thankful
this moment for mayor dinkins
i'm thankful he was here to show us a
better way
uh just his decency and his humanity
what a contrast to some of what we've
seen over this last
few years in our our national life you
know just a reminder that you can be
decent you can be
kind and that that actually is what
moves us forward
so i would just ask everyone in this
holiday season
practice that kindness practice that
decency
david dinkins showed us such a fine
example of it
and it's a time for everyone to look out
for each other
and and express some love to your your
fellow new yorker and that's what he did
and we will be forever grateful to him
for that
thank you everyone
happy